[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى ساعه مفصله من
العربيه يقدمهالكم ابراهيم
بعد القمه السعوديه الصينيه الرياض تحتضن
قيمتين عربيه وخليجيه مع الصين
بعد اعدام شكري
سفير طهران
اسرائيل تهدد بضرب مطار بيروت لخشيتها من
استخدامه من قبل ايران في تهريب اسلحه
الروسي بوت في موسكو بعد وساطه السعوديه
واماراتيه والامريكيه جرينر في طريقها الى
بلدها
وقع العاهل السعودي الملك سلمان مع الرئيس
الصيني شيء جنبي بنك امس في الرياض
الملك سلمان مع الرئيس الصيني بحضور ولي
العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان على قناه
الصداقه التاريخيه بين البلدين وسبل
تعزيزها في شتى المجله
كما شهد ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان والرئيس الصيني على التوقيع عدد من
اتفاقيات التعاون ومذكرات التفاهم من
بينها خطه المواء ما بين رؤيه المملكه
2030 ومبادره الحزام والطريق كما وقع
البلدان على مذكره تفاهم في مجال الطاقه
الهيدروجينيه وتشجيع الاستثمار المباشر
وشملت الاتفاقيات الموقعه كذلك مذكره
تعاونين في مجال الاسكان واخرى خاصه
بتعليم اللغه الصينيه
العلاقه السعوديه الصينيه بالصداقه والثقه
متبادله فخامه الرئيس
بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه والصين وحرص
على ترسيخ جميع الامكانيات الدفع بتلك
الشراكه لمستويات اعلى تخدم مصالح مشتركه
في حفاظ السلم والامن الدوليين ونحن على
ثقه نتائج الايجابيه لهذه اللقاء ستنعكس
بشكل كبير جدا
من جهتها كذا رئيس الصين
سياره ستفتح عصرا جديدا لعلاقات بلادهم مع
المملكه والعالم العربي وشدد على مواصله
الجهود للارتقاء بعلاقات شراكه
الاستراتيجيه الشامله بين الصين والسعوديه
الى مستوى اعلى وزياده المواهمه بين
مبادره الحزام والطريق ورؤيه 2030 واضاف
الرئيس الصيني بان زيارته يكرش التضامن
المجتمع الصيني والعربي لبناء المستقبل
نحو عصر جديد لافتا الى اقامه الصين
علاقات الشراكه الاستراتيجيه الشامله مع
اثنتي عشر دوله عربيه وتحقيقهم انجازات
وصفها بالايقونيه والخارقه في شتى
المجالات هذا واكد شيء جنبينج المضيق قدما
لبناء علاقته استراتيجيه الصينيه الخليجيه
التي تشهد تطورا سليما ومستقرا وفقا تعبير
في غضون ذلك نقلت وكاله شينخوا عن الرئيس
الصيني شيجن بنك تاكيده ان السعوديه ستكون
في قائمتي مقاصد السائحين الصينيين في
الخارج واكد الرئيس الصيني عزنا بكين
توسعه تبادلات الثقافيه والشعبيه مع
السعودي
وزير الاستثمار السعوديه خالد بن عبد
العزيز الفالح اعلن توقيع 35 اتفاقيه مع
الصين واضاف بان الاتفاقيات الموقعه بين
مؤسسات السعوديه والصينيه شملت قطاعات
العده بينها الطاقه والتعدين والنقل
وسلاسل الامداد كما تضمنت قطاعات الخدمات
اللوجستيه وتصنيع المركبات والرعايه
الطبيه وتقنيه المعلومات
[موسيقى]
خلال ثلاثه عقود اتخذت الصين مكانتها كي
احدى اكبر القوى الاقتصاديه في العالم
دائره الفقر ومستنقع الحروب الذين حاصر
التنين الصيني لسنوات اخرجه اكثر شراسه
ووضعه بمصاف الاقتصادات الاولى عالميا
والسبيل لذلك وفق دراساتنا سياسه التعلم
من الاخطاء في الصين تملصت من براثن مجاعه
لتتحول خلال ثلاثه عقود فقط الى ثاني اكبر
اقتصادا في العالم بعد معالجتها لثلاثه
اخطاء
اولها الوثبه العظيمه التي كان يرجى منها
تحويل البلاد من الزراعه الى التصنيعه
لكنها تسببت بمجاعه راحه ضحيتها الملايين
في خمسينيات القرن الماضي ان الخطا الثاني
الذي ارتكبه الزعيم الصيني موتسينج فكان
الثوره الثقافيه بهدف التخلص من معارضه في
الحزب الشيوعيه ثوره اوصلت الولاده لحافه
الانهيار وتسببت بتراجع الدخل الفرديه الى
اقل من 200 دولار سنويا
فيما ثالث الاخطاء يتمثل بالحروب ثلاث
مواجهات مسلحه محدوده زمنيا ومكنيا بين
عام 62 و 79 استنزفت قدرات البلاد
الاقتصاديه وانهكتها هذه الاخطاء علمت
القاده الجدد عدم تطوير الاقتصاد عبر
الصدمات بل اتمامه تدريجيا ليعتده الشعب
ثم تطبيق سياسه الانفتاح على الاستثمار
الاجنبي والقطاع الخاص وتبني النظام
الاقتصاديه الراسمالي في مفارقه غريبه
لبلد شيوعيه وبعد ان كان نصيبها من الناتج
الاجمالي العالمي لا يتجاوز واحدا فاصل
ثمانيه في المئه عام
حققت قفزه النوعيه مع ارتفاع هذا الرقم
الى 16% عام 2020 اي ان اقتصادها تضاعف
نحو تسع مرات خلال اقل من سبعه عقود كما
اصبح القطاع الخاص يساهم بن 60% من
الاقتصاد الصيني
ورغم ان تجربه الصينيه غير قابله للاسقاط
بحذافيرها على اقتصادات المنهكه لبعض
الدول العربيه بسبب اختلاف بعدد السكان
والمساحه والموارد الطبيعيه لكنها اكثر
قابليه للتطبيق في بعض الدول خاصه تلك
التي تجمع بين الموارد الطبيعيه والبشريه
والاستقرار السياسي وتستطيع البدء في
السير في طريق التنميه
السعوديه
اليوم قمهتين عربيه وخليجيه مع الصين وقد
توافذ القاده العرب للمشاركه في القلمتين
العربيه والخليجيه حيث وصل الرئيس المصري
عبد الفتاح السيسي وهو ولي العهد الكويتيه
الشيخ مشعل احمد اضافه الى رئيس الوزراء
العراقي محمد شياع السوداني هو رئيس مجلس
السياده السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان
والرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس وعدد من
القاده والزعماء العرب ورئيس جيبوتي
الاسماعيلي
تجمع دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي بالصين
علاقات شاركت اقتصاديه قويه خلال هذا
العام كشف سفراء الصين لدى دول مجلس
التعاون عن حجم التبادل التجاري حيث حلت
الصين محل الاتحاد الاوروبي منذ العام
2020 واصبحت اكبر شريك تجاريا لمجلس
التعاون
جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه الصديقه
تكون العلاقات الخليجيه الصينيه كما هي
اليوم بهذه القوه
فالرئيس دنشوبنج الذي قاد الصين بنعام 78
و92 ادرك ان حاجه بلاده لمصادر الطاقه
وتحريك الاقتصاد تحتاج الى نظام امني
مستقر ووجده في الخليج الذي يشكل حصه
الاسد في والده الصين من النفط والغاز
والبتروكيماويات وبالفعل استطاعت الصين
تاسيس حضورها الاقتصادي في الخليج بدخول
العلاقات مرحله جديده خلال سبعين عاما من
التقارب السياسي الذي احدث تطور اقتصادي
مذهلا وما زال في مرحله التحول
حيث اصبحت الصين اكبر شريك تجاري لمجلس
التعاون منذ عام 2020 وحلت محل الاتحاد
الاوروبي السعوديه تتصدر لائحه شركاء
الصين التجاريين بين الدول العربيه فيما
تجاوز مستوى التبادل التجاري بين الامارات
والصين 64 مليار دولار وتربعت الصين على
راس قائمه الدول الاسيويه من حيث حجم
التبادل التجاري مع سلطنه عمان بمبلغ 8.3
مليار ريال عماني وبلغ حجم التبادل
التجاري بين الكويت والصين 20.2 مليار
دولار في الاحد 10 شهرا الاولى من عام
2011 فيما اكد السفير الصين لدى قطر ان
حجم المبادلات التجاريه مع بلاده تجاوز 18
مليار دولار
وتجاوز حجم التبادل التجاري بين البحرين
والصين
المليارين دولار
وبحسب الارقام فان التعاون بين المجلس
التعاون والصين في الطاقه يتطور بخطن
ثابته ومستمر نحو اتجاه اكثر عمقا واتساعا
في استخراج النفط والغاز الطبيعي
وتكرير النفط ميس الحربي العربي
للبكين في الشرق الاوسط بما في ذلك رحلات
عده لرئيس الصيني سجن بيج الى دول عربيه
خليجيه واعتبر الاعلام بالصينيه الزيارات
نوعا جديدا من العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
والدوليه التي ضاعفت مشاركه بكين
الاقتصاديه في المنطقه العربيه بشكل اكبر
تبعد الصين عن الشرق الاوسط بما يقرب
السته الاف كيلو متر ولكن بكين حاضره
باستثماراتها العبره للحدود
ونجحت بان تكون المستثمر رقم واحد في دول
العربيه وهذا يعود لمستوى علاقاتها وخصوصا
مع الدول الخليجيه فكيف باتت الشركه
الاقتصاديه الاول للدول العربيه
من خلال حجم صادراتها الضخمه الى هذه
الدول
واستحواذها على حصه الاسد من صادرات هذه
الدول النفطيه واستثمارتها
ثقيله الاستثمارات الصينيه في المنطقه
العربيه والشرق الاوسط ارتفعت بنسبه 360
بالمئه خلال العام الماضي وحده في ما
ارتفعت قيمه الاستثمارات الصينيه في قطاع
البناء في هذه المنطقه بنسبه مئه وسته عشر
بالمئه وبذلك باتت قيمه الاستثمارات
الصينيه في ثقتي العربيه وحدها تتجاوز
حدود المئتين وثلاثه عشر مليارا و 900
مليون دولار في نهايه العام 2021
والسعوديه تستاثر بنصيب الاسد من هذه
الاستثمارات وتاليها الامارات ثم العراق
ومصر رابع الدول العربيه
استقطابا للاستثمارات الصينيه اما عن
الاستثمارات العربيه المباشره في الصين
فلا توجد ارقام رسميا ولكن الارقام
المتداوله في الاعلام ان الاستثمارات
العربيه المباشره في الصين عام 2020
بلغت اكثر من ثلاثه مليارات و800 مليون
دولار واي كان الرقم فان الدرس المستفاده
للاستثمارات العربيه الخارجيه وبخاصه
الخليجيه هو تنوع مجالات واماكن الاستثمار
وهو ما جعل الصين ودور جنوب شرق اسيا منذ
ذلك الوقت وجهه مقبوله استثمارات الخارجيه
لدول الخليج العربي
ميس الحربي العربي العربيه
السعوديه بعلاقات ثنائيه قويه مع غالبيه
دول العالم لكنها وقعت في اتفاقيات شراكه
استراتيجيه مع بعض هذه الدول اللاسيه
الكبرى منها
[موسيقى]
تمثل الصيني والدول العربيه قوتين
سياسيتين مهمتين على ساحه الدوليه وانطلق
عهد جديد في العلاقه الصينيه العربيه
بتاسيس الصين الجديده عام 49 واستقلال
الدول العربيه تباعا
ورغم البعد الجغرافي الصداقه الصينيه
العربيه ممتده لالاف السنين والتواصل
التاريخي القديم وسجل رسميا في اسرتها
الصينيه التي حكمت عام 202 قبل الميلاد
اما دبلوماسيا فلسطين الجديد التي تاسست
عام
حافظت على الاتصال الوثيق مع دول الشرق
الاوسط
وعلامتها 71 عاما تعمقه الثقه السياسيه
بين العرب والصينيين بانشاء مصر عام
علاقات دبلوماسيه
لتلتحق بعد ذلك ست دول عربيه هي سوريا
والعراق واليمن والمغرب والجزائر والسودان
وضل الدعم السياسي المتبادل ركيزه
الاساسيه للعلاقات وكانت الصين متحمسه
للقضايا العربيه فكان موقفها واضحا من
الاعتداء الذي شدته بريطانيا وفرنسا
واسرائيل ضد مصر حرب السويس عام 1956
وكانت اول دوله غير عربيه تعترف بالحكومه
المؤقته للجمهوريه الجزائريه عام
1958 وايضا كانت اول دوله غير عربيه تعترف
بمنظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه
واقترحت غير مره مبادرات بشان القضيه
الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليه والاتفاق النووي
الايراني وامن الخليج والازمه السوريه
وغيرها من المواقف الداعمه للدول العربيه
في المقابل كانت دعم العربي للصين في كافه
المحافل الدوليه كبيرا ايضا في الدول
العربيه رفعت اصواتها الداعمه للصين مرارا
وتكرارا في مجلس حقوق الانسان التابع
للامم المتحده في القضايا التي تتعلق بشين
جيانك والتبت وغيرها
ميس الحربي العربي العربيه
[موسيقى]
قال مسلسل الامن القومي الامريكي جيك
سيلفن ان الاعدام الظالم والوحشي للشاب
محسن شكري فيما يتصل بالاحتجاجات في ايران
يعد محاوله لترويع الشعب الايراني واضاف
عبر حسابه على تويتر سنحاسب النظام
الايراني على العنف الوحشي الذي يمارسه ضد
شعبه وكانت منظمه حقوق الانسان الايرانيه
افادت ان تهمه اغلاق الشوارع واصابه رجل
ام بسكين وجهت لشكاري قبل ان يهدمه النظام
بوحشيه
من جانبه قال ممثل امريكي الخاص في ايران
روبرت مارينا اعدام السلطات الايرانيه
لمحسن شكاري بعد محاكمه صوريه صعيد خطير
ضمن محاولتها لقمع المعارضه واضاف على
تويتر بان واشنطن تواصل التنسيق مع
الحلفاء والشركاء للتصدي الانتهاكات حقوق
الانسان التي ترتكبها ايران
[موسيقى]
سرعه الخارجيه الالمانيه السفير الايراني
في برلين وفقما على انه مصدر مقرب من
الوزاره عاقبه طهران اول حكم بالاعدام
مرتبطا بالاحتجاجات التي تشهدها ايران ولم
تتضح اي معلومات متعلقه بهذا الاستدعاء
حتى الان لكنه وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه
انا لينا بربك كتبت في وقت سابق على تويتر
ان ازدراء النظام الايراني الانسانيه لا
حدود له
فقد طالبت اسره الشاب محسن شكري متظاهرين
الايرانيين بالانتفاضه لثار فيما دعت
منظمه حقوقيه ايرانيه للكشف عن مصير
العشرات من المحتجين المعتقلين الذين يرفض
النظام الكشف عن مصيرهم بينما تتخوف اسر
هؤلاء من ان يكون مصيرهم كمصير محسن شكري
الاعدام
بعد مهاجمته وجرحه عنصر من قوات الباسيج
نفذ النظام الايراني اول اعدام مرتبط
بالاحتجاجات في ايران الشاب محسن شكاري
حول استئناف الحكم لكن طلبه بالرفض بعد ان
حدد قضاء النظام مصيره بالشنقي حتى الموت
وفي طابور انتظار هناك 11 ايرانيه تلقى
ذات الاحكام وجميعها اتخذت خلال
الاحتجاجات الاخيره فيما تعتبرها منظمه
العفو الدوليه محاكمات سوريه كما تؤكد
منظمه الايرانيه لحقوق الانسان انها لا
تستند الى اي اجراءات قانونيه تلك
الاحتجاجات التي تعوم المدن الايرانيه
يلعبوا الشباب فيها دورا بارزه لكنهم
يتعرضون بالمقابل الى اساليب متنوعه من
القمه قرابه 500 ايراني بينهم 60 قاصرا
قتلوا في الاحتجاجات لحسب صحيفه واشنطن
بوست بين شافت مراكز حقوقيه عن نحو 18,000
شخص قالت انهما تقول منذ سبتمبر في ايران
ووجهت اتهامات الى 36 منهم على الاقل
بجرائم يعاقب عليها بالاعدام
ويحرم نظام عاده المتهمين من الاتصال
بمحامين بل يمثلهم محامون تعينهم محاكمه
عنف النظام والاحكام التي توصف بالجائره
بحق المحتاجين يبدو انها كسرت حاجز الخوف
لدى المتظاهرين الذين تقولوا تقارير محليه
انهم يلقون تشجيعه للاستمرار من ابائهم
وحتى اجدادهم حنان المصري العربيه
وبعد انتهاء اضراباتي الايام الثلاثه التي
عمت نحو 60 مدينه ايرانيه عدد زخم
الاحتجاجات مجددا الى الشوارع والمدن
الايرانيه بدا من العاصمه طهران التي رفع
فيها المحتجون شعارات التظاهر في بعض محطه
مترو وفي حافلات النقل العام في الطرق
المؤديه الى شارع ازادي وانقلاب بالعاصمه
اضافه لمدن ذات غبيه كرديه وبلوشيه اثريه
باطل
لمصر
[تصفيق]
في تصريحات خاصه
الجمهوري تومي توبرفيل عن امله بتقديم
الاداره الامريكيه مزيده من الدعم
للمحتجين في ايران
من جديد اخذ السنه الجمهوريه روجر مارشال
العربيه انه يجب على اداره بايدينا الدفاع
دائما عن الحريه والتعزيز ذات الفرصه
لكافه الدول فيديو
السماح بذلك في الوقت الراهن
افادت صحيفه تايمز وفي اسرائيل ان اسرائيل
هددت بشن ضربتهم على مطار بيروت الدوليه
لاحباط تهريب شحنه اسلحه ايرانيه الى
لبنان عبر الرحلات المدنيه الصحيفه اوضحت
ان تهديد الاسرائيلي جاء بعد اشتباه
اسرائيل في محاوله طهران تهريب اسلحه عبر
مطار بيروت عن طريق شركه معراج المرتبطه
بالحرس الثوري الايراني
تهريب جديد عبر مطار بيروت بعد فشل ممرضه
دمشق
الرحلات المدنيه الايرانيه الى لبنان تهرب
السلاح اسرائيل تكشف عن مسار الجديد
لتهريب سلاح ايران الى ميليشيا حزب الله
هذه المره عبر خطوط معراج التابعه للحرس
الثوري بشكل الاسبوعي يشهد مطار بيروت
الدولي هبوط رحلات ايرانيه تابعه لشركه
معان اير وايران اير لكن في الاسابيع
الاخيره بدات شركه معراج الايرانيه بتسيير
رحلاتها الى لبنان في نهج غير اعتيادي حطت
الرحله الاولى في الرابعه عشر من نوفمبر
مصادر العربيه افادت ان رحلات معراج
لبيروت قد تنقل اسلحه ومعدات حساسه لحزب
الله وان اسرائيل تخشى انضمامه مطار بيروت
الى مسار تهريب الاسلحه من ايران للبنان
عبر هذه الرحلات
المصادر اكدت ان هذا النوع من المحور في
نقل الاسلحه فيعرض لبنان للخطر عدا ان
استغلال مطار بيروت في نقل اسلحه ايرانيه
سيضر بالاقتصاد اللبناني وقد يعرض لبنان
للعقوبات والعزله الدوليه
على مر السنوات
القدس على نقل اسلحه من ايران الى سوريا
ومن هناك الى لبنان مثل مكونات انظمه
الدفاع جوي وصواريخ ارض ارض دقيقه بهدف
تعزيز دور مليشه حزب الله وتقويته بالسلاح
نقل المعدات الى لبنان يمر عبر محاوره
متعدده المحور البري وذلك باستخدام شاحنات
والمركبات وعبورها المعابر الحدوديه من
العراق الى سوريا المحور البحري باستخدام
السفن الايرانيه التي تبحر الى ميناء
اللاذقيه في سوريا والمحور الجوي من ايران
الى سوريا باستخدام الخطوط الجويه
الايرانيه ومن هناك الى لبنان عبر وكلاء
النقل التابعين لميليشيا حزب الله ملوك
الشيخ العربيه
مع رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي الجديد
هرسه
الجهود المشتركه بين البلدان التصدي
لتهديدات ايران ونقلت وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه في بيان عن كالتاكيده خلال
الاجتماع التزام الولايات المتحده بضمان
تفوق اسرائيل العسكري النوعي والخطوات
اللازمه لزياده التعاون العسكري الثنائي
هكذا وزير الاعلام اليمني معمر الارياني
مواصله النظام الايراني نقل الاسلحه
والتكنولوجيا العسكريه من صواريخ باريستيه
والطائرات مسيره لجماعه الحوثي مشددا على
انتهاكها السفر للقرارات الدوليه الارياني
اتهم طهران ايضا بمحاوله الهروب من
ازماتها الداخليه عبر تحريك ادواتها في
المنطقه اللي زعزعه الامن والاستقرار
وتحديد امن الطاقه العالميه اضافه الى
خطوط الملاحه الدوليه
في تصريحات العربيه عبر سنه الامريكي
الجمهوري لينسيجرام عن قلقه بشان رفع
منشيئه الحوثي من قائمه الارهاب الدوري
وزاره الداخليه الالمانيه تدعو لاعاده
النظر في المؤسسات الامنيه بعد احباط
انقلاب الرايش
اهلا بكم من جديد وصل تاجر السلاح السابق
فيكتور بوت الى موسكو بعد الافراج عنه في
صفقه تبادل مع واشنطن شملت لاعبه كره
السله الامريكيه بريتني
من العمر 55 عاما في ظل توترات بين
البلدين على خلفيه النزاع في اوكرانيا
تمام
اه كانت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه
والاماراتيه على نتاع نجاح الوساطه التي
قادها ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان ورئيس دوله الامارات العربيه
المتحده الشيخ محمد بن زايد وقد اكد بيان
سعودي اماراتي مشترك ان نجاح وسلطه تبادل
السجناء تعكس علاقات صداقه مع امريكا
وروسيا واشار البيان الى ان ابوظبي
استقبلت الامريكيه بريتنير عبر طائره خاصه
قادمه من موسكو وذلك بالتزامن مع استقبال
روسيفكتور بوت عبر طائره خاصه قادمه من
واشنطن واوضح البان السعودي الاماراتي
المشترك ان عمليه تبادل السجناء بين موسكو
واشنطن تمت عبر مطار ابو ظبي كما عرب
البيان عن شكر المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والامارات العربيه المتحده لحكمتي امريكا
وروسيا لتعاونه مال انجحه وساطه تبادل
السجناء
من البيت الابيض
ان لاعبه كره السله الامريكيه بريتني
جراوند
[موسيقى]
الى الولايات المتحده
بعد عشره اشهر من اعتقال اللاعب الفائزه
بميداليتين ذهبيتين اولمبيتين بتهمه
من افضل لاعبات كره السله في العالم وصلت
الى روسيا في فبراير من اجل اللاعبين ضمن
احد النوادي في الاورال خلال فتره توقف
الدوري الامريكي الامر الذي دفع بالاتحاد
الاسائي لكره السله الامريكيه بالاعتراض
على اعتقالها واعتبارها اعتقالا ظالما
ربنا
وانت بخير
عمليات تبادل الاسرى شهره بين البلدين منذ
الحرب البارده ولم يفضح عن بنودها
في الوقت الذي تحتفل فيه عائله
من السجناء الامريكيين قابعين في السجون
الروسيه دون معرفه مصيرهم او موعد انتهاء
معاناتهم مع عدم اعلان الاداره الامريكيه
اي خطوات فعاليه لاستمرار اي مفاوضات مع
روسيا حول اوضاعهم سليمان العربيه
وبعد اطلاق سراح بريتني جراينر معتقل
سابقه في موسكو سالت مراسله العربيه
المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض كارين جبير عن
الاتهامات الموجهه للبيت الابيض بالزواجيه
المعايير بما يتعلق بالرهائن الامريكيين
المحتجزينها في الخارج
لا يمكنني التحدث عنها حاليا
اود ان احيلك الى وزاره الخارجيه للحصول
على تطورات هذا الموقع ما يمكنني اخبارك
به هو ان الرئيس ملتزم باعاده المواطنين
الامريكيين الذين يحتجزون بشكل غير صحيح
في الخارج
المانيا تعيش صدمه محاوله انقلاب التي
احبطت من جهه تنتمي لاقصى اليمين لكن
الاجهزه الامنيه لا وقت لديها للصدمه
فالاستخبارات الالمانيه قالت انها مجموعه
الراخر متطرفه كانت تخطط لعمل خطر في
البلاد بينما دعت وزاره الداخليه لاعاده
النظر عن قرب في المؤسسات الامنيه خاصه
وان المخطط كان اضخم مما ياتي
في المانيا يبدو ان ما اطل براسه امس هو
فقط راس شبح النازي اما الجذور فاعميقه
على غير المتوقع عمليات الاعتقال التي
انطلقت لتفكيك مجموعه من اقصى اليمين كان
هدفها الانقلاب على الدوله تتواصل تضاعف
عدد من يخدعون للتحقيق ليتخطى 50 في رقم
بعيد عن ان يكون نهائيا لكن اخطر ما في
العمليه تكشفه
مخطط الانقلاب لم يكن يقتصر فقط على
اقتحام مقر البرلمان بل اغتيال راس الدوله
المستشاردز مع عدد من المشرعين الذين
تصرفهم المجموعه الانقلابيه بالاعداء
تقرير صحيفه الامريكيه اشار ايضا الى ان
المخطط كان يهدف الى تخريب شبكه الكهرباء
لتسهيل عمليه الانقلاب وان عناصر المجموعه
اشتروا بالفعل هواتف وتعمل بالاقمار
الصناعيه لضمان بقاء التواصل بينهم خلال
مراحل التنفيذ الانقلاب المزمار
اما الجانب الذي يبعث على الاطمئنان حتى
الان فهو سقوط الراس المدبر الامير هنري
الثالث عشر الذي كان يريد ان ينصب نفسه
رئيسا جديدا للبلاد في حال نجاح الانقلاب
المتهم الرئيسي في القضيه ينحدر من عائله
رئيس الملكيه الالمانيه ويبلغ من العمر 71
عاما وهو رجل اعمال النشطه في مجال
العقارات ومقيم في مدينه فرانكفورت بوسط
المانيا وكان سيتم في حال نجاح الانقلاب
اعلان حكومه جديده في ظل قيادته وتشكيل
جيش الماني جديد
حتى الان من غير الواضح مدى قدره المجموعه
على تنفيذ مخططها لكن الاكيده ان ضخامه
عدد المشتبه بهم ووجود حديث عن الاتصالات
مع روسيا او غيرها يشيل بان المحاوله لم
تكن له هو وادى النازيه التي يتبرا منها
الالمان منذ عقود لم تموت
[موسيقى]
في ملف الحرب الاوكرانيه اكد الرئيس
الروسي الذي من بوتين انا بلاد هو ستواصل
ضربتها ضد البنت
على الهجمات التي الحقت اضرار الجسيمه
بجسر القرم وهجمات الاخرى قامت بها
اوكرانيا
وفيما يلمح رئيس روسي من انه لن يستخدم
السلاح النوويه تزداد وتيره المخاوف من
تصاعد خطر الحرب النوويه فبوتن حضر ان
بلاده تمتلك اسلحه متطوره
لن تهدا ولا افق لنهايتها هي حرب طويله
الامد لكن الى متى لا حدا يدري سوى الرئيس
في الحرب الاكرانيه يتصاعد خطر الحرب
النوويه المسؤولون الروس يؤكدونا ان قوه
الردع النووي في حاله تاهب تام لغه تحذير
وتهديد لم تهدا منذ اشهر
انه لن يستخدمه السلاح النووي ابقى الباب
مفتوحا على كل الخيارات الرد سيكون بالمثل
على اي هجوم نووي
موسكو اكدت ايضا الالتزامها بتعليق نشر
الصواريخ النوويه متوسطه المدى في اوروبا
ما دامت الولايات المتحده لم تنشر مثل تلك
الاسلحه في اوروبا او
اسياها في اغسطس 2019 بسبب سياسات
التدميريه للولايات المتحده وانسحابها
منها والان هناك فراغ في اللوائح الدوليه
بمجال الصواريخ النوويه يمكن ان يكون له
مخاطر اضافيه على الامن العالميه
قطر النووي الا ان الامين العام لحلف
الناتو يرى ان خطر استخدام روسيا للنووي
في اوكرانيا ضئيل لكنه مازال ياخذ الامور
على محمل الجده
بالتوجه عمدا لتصعيد الصراع في اوكرانيا
كما تتهم الغرب والنيتو باللعب بالنار
خصوصا في توسعه بتسليم اسلحه بعيده المدى
والاثقل لاوكرانيا من دون قيود
لكن بالتزامن مع هذا التوتر هناك بوادر
للتهدئه فالمستشار الالماني يرى ان خطر
اللجوء روسيا للنووي تراجع لان المجتمع
الدولي رسم خطا احمر لروسيا على هذا
الصعيد والاهم ان شغلت قرر دعوه مكرون
لمناقشه الضمانات الامنيه التي طلبها بوتن
قبل اشهر واحد انهاء عمليته والانسحاب من
اوكرانيا
في مدينتي بخمس ما زالت قوات فجنه الروسيه
تطوق المدينه من ناحيتين جنوبيه الشرقيه
والجنوبيه الغربيه في محاوله الدخول الى
باخمود وسط الدفاع شرس من قبل الجيش
الاكرانيه
[موسيقى]
كشفت وكاله روتانا وزاره الخزانه
الامريكيه تتجه لفرض عقوبات ضد رجل اعمال
تركي يدعى صدقي ايان لدوره في عمليه تهريب
النفط الايراني وعمليه غسل اموال لصالح
الحرس الثوري الايراني وبحسب الوزاره فان
رجل الاعمال التركيه المذكور ابرم صفقات ب
100 ملايين من الدولارات كما قامت شركاته
بتحويل هذه الاموال لصالح فيلق القدس
التابعي للحرس الثوري الايراني
نشاطنا مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعض الفاصل
بسبب شجاعته ومقاومته الرئيس الاوكراني
شخصيه العام 2022 وفق مجله دعم الامريكيه
اهلا بكم من جديد قتلت القوات الاسرائيليه
ثلاثه فلسطينيين في جنين واصابه عددا اخر
بجروح خلال عمليه عسكريه زادت من نسبه
التوتر المرتفعه اصلا في اغلب المناطق
الضفه الغربيه
ليله صعبه اخرى في جنين القوات
الاسرائيليه تقتحمت المدينه الاعتقال عدد
من المطاردين ولكن قبل ان تصل اليهم كانت
قد قتلت عددا من الشبان احدهم كان في
طريقه الى عمله وفق شهود عيان
كانت اطلاق النار
مشاهد الوداع هذه تكررت في جنين 58 مره
منذ بدايه العام المدينه التي اتسمت بشكل
المسلح للمقاومه دفعت النصيب الاكبر من
الضحايا حيث تؤكد الاحصاءات ان هذا العام
كان الاكثر دمويه على الفلسطينيين منذ
العام 2006
[موسيقى]
وتتضرع اسرائيل في عملياتها داخل المدن
الفلسطينيه بانها تلاحق مطلوبين ومنفذين
محتملين لعمليات ضد اهداف لها في الضفه
والداخل
مواكب التشييع المتواصله سواء في جنين او
هنا في رام الله وغيرها من المدن
الفلسطينيه تصب زيت الغضب على نار التصعيد
دون ان تستبعد اسرائيل ان يكون الانفجار
هناك في الجنوب مع قطع غزه من بلده سلواد
عبد الحفيظ جوان العربيه الاراضي
الفلسطينيه
الاوروبي على دخول كرواتيا منطقه شنغنغ
بدايه من شهر يناير المقبل بينما تم رفضه
طلبه رومانيا وبلغاريا واصبحت كرواتيا او
كرواتيا العضو السابع والعشرين في منطقه
تشنجن حيث يمكن لاكثر من 400 مليون شخص
يتنقل فيها بحريه من دون قيود داخليه على
الحدود واعترضت النمسا على الترشيح
بلغاريا ورومانيا حيث اكد وزير الداخليه
النمساويه
شهدت 100,000 عمليه عبور غير قانونيه
للحدود في النمسا
الشجاعه قد تكون معديه كالخوف بهذه
العباره وصفت مجله دعم الامريكيه حصيله من
ترشح عن شخصيه العام 2022 شخصيه هذا العام
التي اخترتها المجله هي الرئيس الاوكرانيه
بلودا ميل سيليسك
[موسيقى]
طفله سوريه تتمنى اللحاق بوالدها المتوفي
بسبب الالم الذي وصلت اليه هي وافراد
عائلتها لفقدانهم الدفء والغذاء خاصه مع
بدايه فصل الشتاء الخارجي الطفل من الشمال
السوري شرحت واقعها المريض عبر تسجيل
المصور انتشر بشكل واسع
انا بابا شهيد قبل ما يموت كان عندنا على
طول حطب كان يدفينا على طول كانه دفيانين
على زمان بابا بس هلا
[موسيقى]
كل شيء خرا
صار باب محل ونحن احنا شو ذنبنا نبراد
لا يبدو ان حمى متابعه كاس العالم تنتشر
في المدينه كحال اغلب منذ العالم كاس
العالم وذلك بسبب المتعه المفقوده جراء
الظروف المعاشيه الصعبه في وقت يعيش فيه
معظم الشعب الافغاني في مناطق غنائيه حيث
لا كهرباء تمكنهم مشاهده مباريات بالاضافه
الى اهمال الحكومه الى المرافق الرياضيه
الزميل عبد الله نادر تبعه اهتمام الشباب
الافغاني بكاس العالم واعد لنا التقرير
الثاني
في هذا الفندق وسط مدينه كابول العاصمه
يشاهد عدد القليل من الشباب الافغاني كاس
العالم يقول معظمهم ان الظروف الاقتصاديه
الصحبه في البلاد والضغوطات النفسيه لا
تترك لهم فرصه التمتع بما يدور في كاس
العالم اما صاحب الفندق فيلقي باللائمه
على السلطات الافغانيه لعدم رغبه الشباب
في مشاهده الرياضه
الاهتمام بالرياضه وخاصه كره القدم سير
رجال طالب جامعي من المهتمين بالرياضه
يحضر يوميا الى هذا الفندق ليشاهد كاس
العالم يضيف ان بعضا من الشباب الافغان
مثله مولعون بكره القدم ولكل منهم منتخبه
المفضل همم
الشباب الافغاني يشاهدون كره القدم في كاس
العالم التي تدور في قطر وانا شخصيا
اشاهدها كل يوم وانا من محبي منتخب
الارجنتين هنا وفي هذا الملعب وتزامنا مع
كاس العالم تلعب فرق افغانيه مختلفه والتي
توجهت الى كابول من جميع المقاطعات التي
يبلغ عددها 34 مقاطعه
موت نشاهد بطوله كاس العالم نعم بعض من لا
يشاهدها في المنازل والفنادق واخرون
يشاهدونها في المكاتب والمحلات التجاريه
[موسيقى]
تعرض العاب كاس العالم في قطر في اماكن
خاصه مثل الفنادق والمقاهي وليست في اماكن
عامه يسهل عليها التردد لكل من اراد
مشاهدتها كاس العالم يبدا فيما لا تمتلك
افغانستان منتخبا وطنيا بعد سيطره طالبان
حيث تم اخراج اعضاء المنتخب الوطني
بمساعده الفيفا بعد وصول طالبانا للسلطان
هذه العربيه كابول اخبار الرياضه
يواجه المنتخب البرازيلي نظيره الكرواتي
ضمن ربوع نهائي كاس العالم
كرواتيا وسنقوم بدراستها بكل الطرق حتى
نكون مستعدين لمواجهتها
كثير من الجوده الفرديه ونحن مستعيدون
لهذه المعركه
وفي لقاء اخر من ربوع النهائي من البطوله
يلاقي المنتخب الارجنتيني نظره الهولندي
ستظل حظوظنا في الفوز بكاس العالم قائمه
كل شيء ممكن لدينا حساب نريد تصفيته مع
الارجنتين ولذلك سيكون من الجيد ان يفوز
النهائي يمكنها الوصول الى نهائي البطوله
الفرص متساويه بين الجميع والتفاصيل تحسم
الامر امام هولندا ستكون مباراه جميله
ورائعه هدفنا التركيز على الفوز في الوقت
الاصلي هذا امر مهم
عين الاتحاد الاسباني لكره القدم لو
استلاف وانت مدربا جديدا للمنتخب الاول
خالفا لويس انريكي المقال بالمنصب
اكد لاتحاد الانجليزي
التي اشارت الى تهديد النجم كريستيانو
رونالدو
بمغادره معسكر الفريق في الدوحه قبل ان
ينفي اللاعب ذلك في تغريده له عبر حسابه
في تويتر
وديا خاسر الهلال السعودي امام ضيفه
نيوكاسل الانجليزيه في خمسه اهداف في
المباراه التي جرت في العاصمه الرياض
في نهايه مشاهده تفكيرهم بابرزي عناوينها
بعد قمه السعوديه الصينيه الرياض تحتضن
قمتين عربيه وخليجيه مع الصين
بعد اعدام شكري واشنطن تلوح بمحاسبه
النظام على عنفه والمانيا تستدعي سفيرات
طهران
اسرائيل تهدده بضرب مطار بيروت لخشيتها من
استخدامه من قبل ايران في تهريب اسلحه
وبعد وساطه سعوديه اماراتيه الروسي بوت في
موسكو والامريكيه في طريقها الى بلدها
ختام هذه النشره شكرا لكم متابعه والى
اللقاء